these are the last moments of George
Floyd's life unarmed handcuffed and
pinned to the ground a policeman's knee
on his neck as he pleads for air
the officer is unmoved this went on for
minutes the watching crowd growing
increasingly finally mr. Floyd fell
silent he later died in hospital the 46
year old security guard was described as
a gentle giant his death has reopened
old wounds here and the dismissal of the
four police officers far from enough for
his family to be charged with murder
because that's exactly what they did
they murdered my brother he was crying
for help I don't need them to be
suspended and able to work in another
state or another County their license
should be taken away their job should be
taken away and they should be put in
jail for murder the mayor of Minneapolis
offered this apology to the black
community to the family I'm so sorry
but the protests in mr. Floyd's name
have grown hundreds marching through the
streets of Minneapolis calling for
justice when some converged on a police
station officers responded by firing
tear gas into the crowd America of
course has been here before the death of
Eric garner in New York six years ago as
he told officers he couldn't breathe
while being restrained caused similar
outrage the videos of the treatment of
african-american men by police have laid
bare an uncomfortable truth for
Americans it is Minneapolis now seeing
the full force of that anger directed at
those who swear to protect and serve
another city where people feel justice
in America
is far from equal reg Milam Sky News